[MUSIC]
>> It was past midnight, but I was ready.
The next day, I meet with the CEO and
other senior leaders of my
global consulting firm.
I talked about the work we were doing as
employee resource groups and our progress,
and diversity, and inclusion.
For the past two years,
I had been leading our LGBTQ and
ally employee resource group and
we were doing great things.
We had expanded to over
25 offices globally.
We were increasing awareness and
support across geographies.
These are just a few of the wins
that I was really excited to
talk about the next day.
Earlier, I had rehearsed with the head
of our diversity and inclusion team.
She was thrilled by the presentation.
There was just one last
thing that I had to do.
She asked me if I was going to wear
my nail polish to the meeting.
Now, I didn't think much
of it in the moment.
I would often take off my nail
polish to meet with clients.
But that night, it felt different.
I couldn't help, but
feel as I went finger by finger that
I was removing a part of myself.
Now, I get that nail polish
seems like something trivial.
But to me, it is so tied to my identity.
It's like my cross or
my hijab in that I wear it as
a symbol to world about my queerness and
I wear it as a symbol to myself
about who I am, and my journey.
I wear it like armor to feel confident and
to overcome the insecurity that
I have felt for so many years.
So that night, I had an uh-huh moment.
I thought maybe I've slipped
through a crack in our DNI.
Tonight, I'm going to talk about the work
being done in diversity and inclusion.
I'm going to talk about what's going
well and how it can be improved.
In doing so, I'm going to emphasize
the importance of thinking
more about individuality in our
work in DNI as practitioners,
business leaders and people.
So for those of you who aren't quite sure
what DNI is, diversity and inclusion.
It's a firm's formal set of activities
to create a workplace where
people of all backgrounds
feel welcomed and valued.
It includes things like non-bias
trainings, mentorship programs and
recruitment initiatives.
When it's done well,
it can have business impacts.
In fact, in a recent survey,
85% of CEOs said that DNI
programs were improving
their bottom lines.
They talked about things
like greater innovation,
access to new markets and
retaining talent better.
So it's clear that DNI can
improve business performance,
but DNI is not just about bottom lines.
When DNI has done well,
it can have big impacts on individuals.
That means all of us.
Even with my story about nail polish,
I would still argue that
DNI is still essential.
As a queer person, I have a long
complicated relationship with my identity.
So when I'm in a workplace
where I feel included,
I don't have to stress about fitting it or
if I'm being judged.
I can put all of my brain
power into my work.
I deliver better results and
I feel motivated to do so.
Now I assume others in
the audience tonight have had
similar experiences about DNI and
feeling included,
and that underscores the value of DNI for
all of us.
So now that we've talked a little
bit about why DNI is important,
I wanted to think about the ways
that are current approaches may
actually be holding us back.
But traditionally, DNI is organized
around categorical groups.
Think women, veterans, people of color.
This is great and it does bring a lot of
value to firms, but it's not perfect.
I'll focus on two
limitations in particular.
The first is how we think about
the diversity within categories and
the second is how we
handle intersectionality,
which is the interplay across
our different identities.
So for this first idea of
the diversity within categories,
let's go back to my original story.
It's true that we were having a lot
of success for the LGBTQ community.
But as I realized firsthand, it wasn't
success for everyone in that community.
More specifically, we weren't doing enough
for trans and queer people like myself.
See, there was a problem
with working with the group.
We weren't seeing who
wasn't at the table and
we were getting a false
positive on our success.
So as companies work on DNI,
they need to look critically at
the composition of their
diverse communities.
Ask in my company, does LGBTQ
actually include L, G, B, T and Q?
In any company, is every woman white or
is every black employee a man?
We need to take these into
consideration to advance our DNI.
So having talked about this first
limitation around the diversity within
categories, let's think about the second
limitation around intersexuality.
Again, this is the interplay
across our different identities.
And for this, I'm going to talk about
the experience of my friend Erica,
a black woman.
Again, traditional DNI would organize
programs around categorical groups and
there would be programs for
black employees and
others for women and
Erica would opt in to both.
But in her words, she wouldn't
really be there as her full self.
She'd be black Erica had a lunch.
And later that day,
woman Erica had a dinner.
It sounds strange, right?
Now we're all different, but we're all
similar in that we are all complex.
We're all a combination of identities.
Some visible, most invisible.
And so we can all have this experience
where it's hard to be present
as our full selves when we're
only being viewed as categories.
So when working in DNI, we need to make
sure we're designing it for whole people.
So having talked about these
two limitations, the first,
the diversity within categories.
And the second, intersectionality.
But think of what we can
do to get beyond them.
I would suggest that working more around
this idea of individuality is a start and
what might that look like?
Well, it could take
the shape of storytelling.
Think of the impact of Erica's and
my stories tonight.
Think of the impact they and others
could have in sparking discussions, and
shaping workplace culture.
It could take the shape of events
that celebrate intersectionality and
all of our identities,
visible and invisible.
Taken together,
these kinds of programs help us overcome
the current limitation of our work.
We can see and
support new pools of talent.
We can let people show up and
participate as their whole selves,
and not just their parts.
Each of these incremental
gains improves inclusively,
which would attract new forms of diversity
which should lead to even better outcomes.
When I reflect on my experience,
I probably wouldn’t have joined
my firm if it didn’t have DNI.
I probably would have opted out of
consulting and business altogether.
For me, it would have been
easier not to exist in those
worlds than to feel unwelcome or
excluded, but what if I did?
What value would have been lost to
my company, my clients and myself?
DNI gave me a reason to opt-in.
And while it's not perfect, it certainly
part of the reason why I'm here now.
So in preparing for this moment,
I had to ask myself,
should I take off my nail polish?
I can still be insecure
in a lot of settings,
especially ones like this, but
I'm proud to stand up here tonight.
Armor on and ready to go to battle for
a greater focus on individuality
in our work in DNI,
because diversity and
inclusion is business smart.
But designing it for individuals,
that's what makes it human.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]